all right we're back on okay Matthew
what is what was it like working on
almost Heroes with Chris Farley
oh well working with uh Chris was
amazing he's probably the funniest
person I've ever met really um yeah he
was funny yeah he was really really
funny and he would do the strangest
things we were the leads in this movie I
remember it yeah yeah well you're the
only one that uh
Indian girl yes yes and uh whenever he
would have to make an entrance in a
scene we would you know rehearse it and
then do the scene and then whenever he
would do an entrance I would open the
door and he'd be completely naked
thank you
which was funny to me I found it very
funny but the 65 year old script
supervisor was like oh no no no
I mean you could you couldn't even do
that today no I mean they would
immediately cancel yeah over yeah it
would shut down the set he would be
arrested yep true you'd be canceled just
for seeing it I mean it would just
uh Laura what is your Take On the World
Cup being hosted in gutter is that I'm
pronouncing that I've heard it different
Qatar gutter I'm calling it well any
place that has had all the people who
spent time building it up to a thousand
people dying even building it just to be
able to sponsor the event gutter might
be right okay
[Applause]
a thousand people have died I don't know
I'm I hear I hear the reports like
hundreds of people up to a thousand and
the numbers are shaky because I don't
know how many people were involved in
the building and the idea of people
being forced in some respect to
um being this sweltering heat to build
this stadium for profit I mean there is
something we fundamentally have to do
better I know there are Avid sports fans
I know football soccer fans among the
most Avid in the world but there should
be a middle ground that people can
safely participate in the building
well look I'm not first of all right I I
hate soccer as much as I hate Bitcoin
I'm not soccer
I've always been cleared I would they
call me an islamophobe but you know come
on there's some bad things that go on in
countries like this that we should talk
about so I have no dog in this fight but
when you build something people do die I
mean the Panama Canal no the Panama
Canal was not a spot soccer stadium you
don't need soccer and I do need to get
sweatpants a day earlier
or whatever I get from the Panama can I
well I'm just saying even you know Mount
Rushmore completely unnecessary we built
it I'm sure somebody fell off Lincoln's
nose and died right I mean no I mean
they couldn't have been up on that
[ __ ] Mountain for like 12 years with
dynamiting into his eyebrow and nobody
got hurt okay people it really depends
on what was hanging out of his nose
[Applause]
the phrase is if you build it they will
come not if you build it they will die
right
you doing huh but I hear but I hear a
cutter a hair cutter is a lovely place
for other reasons uh I probably would
not be a lovely place for any woman who
wasn't wearing the appropriate dress and
wasn't uh
paying attention to Sharia law and maybe
you know if leave the house without the
permission of a guardian okay that's the
[ __ ] that goes on in places like gutter
that we need to talk about and somehow
the world doesn't because that's not
islamophobia which is [ __ ] it's
violation of every liberal principle
women are equal
so that's what I have against gutter
okay
John do you think Americans will ever
share another collective experience that
engenders a shared understanding
I don't
um
right I don't even know who we don't
have the same Stars anymore like like
people don't yeah I think 911 was was
the last one and I think uh kovid you
know the first weeks of covet actually
may be qualified but but the fact that
we so quickly split and obviously
president Trump has a lead role in that
and with his statements about liberate
Virginia and all but but I think there's
no there's no possibility for a shared
understanding what's happening anymore
um there used to be journalism with
Gatekeepers and say what you want about
it at least having a democracy in which
people have some shared sense of what's
Happening makes it possible to have the
kind of debates and discussions we that
we need so I do think well look if
Twitter collapses actually maybe
it's not just Twitter I mean
you know I mean I mentioned I was giving
a shout out to my brand new love Jay
Leno too we all love Jay Leno I mean
lots of people 20 don't know who that is
and we don't know who the stars that
they're watching are on Tick Tock there
are Tick Tock Stars I've seen it happen
in a restaurant where like these eight
kids come in and they're playing and I'm
like who the [ __ ] is that
you know what they're Tick Tock star
so actually so if you've got a key word
here we talk a lot about polarization
but I think the word I'm moving more to
is fragmentation that everything gets
fragmented and it's not just left right
and within the left there are all kinds
of fights you know within the right well
less so perhaps but
um but no it's between them right now
well now now it is yes now it is civil
war on the right Trump and DeSantis oh I
can't wait to see I just cannot wait for
this
that's why I would love to see Trump
back on Twitter because all he'll do is
attack DeSantis and then we'll see what
he does but it'll be fun yeah but we'll
all get collectively stupider from
having to watch it well we're going to
get stupider I I just don't see I I
don't see America really coming back
until we have that scene at the end of
Planet of the Apes where the Statue of
Liberty's arm is in there you know he
couldn't remember that you damn dirty
eight
[Applause]
let's just enjoy the ride down Matthew
yeah
your mother works
let's just enjoy the road down Matthew
your mother worked as a press secretary
for then prime minister Pierre Trudeau
Justin Trudeau's father
uh how does that association inform your
view of politics
well at first when I was when I was a
young kid I mean my mother basically was
what Allison Janny it was on The West
Wing that's the White House Press
Secretary yeah and uh for Justin
Trudeau's father who was the Prime
Minister for years and years right and
and Dapper guy very Dapper guy and we
went out with some amazing women yes
um
I understand
I totally understand my feeling about
that was that she was working very hard
so I didn't get to see her as much as I
wanted to see it that was basically it
so now there's a big rumor going around
that I beat up Justin Trudeau when we
were kids I saw that yeah and I don't
really believe that I did that but he
but he picked up on it and he tweeted me
back and he said I hit him back because
who wouldn't want to hit Chandler in the
face
come on
and so I treated him back now that you
have your own Army I'm not fighting you
anymore
good luck with all your endeavors
and that was it
Canada has an army Canada is an army it
does yeah it doesn't do much no
red do they the mounty thing yeah yeah
not the Army and the big head thing oh
my God are they on hold well they're not
the they're not the Army they're just
people for show they still do they still
have that mountains Canadians they do
well and they faint all the time it gets
so hard
okay
um eight billion people we passed on the
planet this this week I don't know how
they know that but I guess they you know
it's a rough estimate we don't know who
the guy is
Nick Cannon
we just know Nick Cannon is the father
[Applause]
[Music]
I I
hear people talking all the time about
how we need more people we need less
people I'm like am I crazy about this
Elon Musk wants more people there's lots
of people saying this like oh we gotta
like keep having babies no 8 billion is
already way too much I'm right
okay
I mean I I had two kids I'm done right
yeah okay two done thanks okay that was
just during this show
[Applause]
we still got it it's true
um so um we're still counting votes in
some places we just found out I mean
when was the it was ten days ago was the
why can Brazil do it in three hours and
and we and the votes keep trickling in
what what is it about
they do it in Banks they count things
effectively casinos you know when
money's on the line except for SBF
seem to like be totally cool with it but
we what is that we got to fix imagine
other countries have a much more
centralized uniform system and and I
believe it's the case that each state
makes all of its laws so that's part of
it but yeah you'd think that you know if
we can put a man on the moon we could
count the votes in 10 days we can't put
a man on the moon
we don't put oh yes it's a very
anachronistic saying John oops we we
when was the last time we put a man on
the moon 1972 yes I think 69.
so you know we can't put him in on the
moon but REM had the song in the 90s
right what REM had the song in the 90s
because that counts that was about Andy
Kaufman well fine sue me remember that
song Andy Kaufman's the reason that
there shouldn't be eight million people
on the planet
um
I also read this week about sperm
okay
great I was glad you read the two things
no that sperm counts are dropping you
read this why first of all good because
of the eight billion thing
doesn't bother me at all but I mean
isn't this a bit of a canary in the coal
mine I seem to remember a movie where we
couldn't propagate and they had to keep
the one lady alive who was going to have
a baby because remember that movie okay
so like what's going on with sperm
counts dropping I've been looking into
this because I'm trying to understand
both what's going wrong for girls what's
going on for boys
um and if you look both at circulating
testosterone levels and its sperm counts
both are dropping and there seems to be
a bit more of a steep drop off in the
early 2000s and so I have no idea
whether this is because boys suddenly
started playing a lot more video games
or because videos new Plastics and why
would how would that affect sperm
um well just um you know I don't know
it's just let's we just but it's a
correlation because yeah just what's
your name something psychological can I
mean I've heard that people don't people
kids reach puberty earlier than they
used to yeah I mean when I was a kid it
was 12 12 11 12 was the earliest and now
I think it's much earlier and they've
had and they don't know exactly why that
is there's one one theory for for girls
especially is uh greater body mass index
it is it is the case that that if you're
heavier you for hormonal reasons you
reach puberty earlier so part of the
drop is thought to be because everyone
was getting fatter and that's leveled
off now but I think the other leading
theory is is Plastics and chemicals and
when I was consuming so much I mean
there's now Plastics in the rain so
that's right and aren't they endocrine
disruptors yes that's right so I think
hormonal explanations are probably where
we should be looking here Matthew Perry
your theories about sperm
aren't you glad you did this show yeah
all right that's it congrats chapter 11.
you should know
thank you very much I appreciate it
we'll see you next year